der andere hat zwei messer und ich habe
auch zwei der schriftsteller michael 4
jetzt fliegt es fliegt kreiseln an mir
vorbei ein schriftsteller der nicht
schreibt sondern diktiert bin aber
geschützt da der alte mann wieder
ziemlich hinter mir ist
michael fehr ist stark sehbehindert
diese geschichten gibt es bis jetzt noch
nicht gedruckt
michael fehr wohnt in ausserholligen
berne vorstadt grau hektisch laut ich
finde die shopping-mall posiert die post
wie eine referenz zum lager ja bisher
passiert glauben
das rad bewegt raum zu autor lars berger
energie soja ist so ganz natürlich sich
alle teams im bochumer werk verarbeitet
oder mensch rund energie das erlebte
verarbeiten still spartanisch wirkt die
wohnung von michael schumacher die
stereo ich stelle das haar wenn es nicht
auto fuhr ihm sie kommen die us personen
ina die wohnung ist mehr als ein zuhause
sie ist sein innenraum labor seiner
rhythmischen prosa weiß nicht wie
brisant wieder andere die innere stimme
mehr ich sie sehr brisant
zimmerli berg
erstes kapitel ein schweizer wetter
michael fehr ist nahe dem emmental
aufgewachsen
wer sie berg ist kein realer ort aber
inspiriert von dieser gegend was mir
hier sehr chaotisch die lieblich kräht
wo ganz plötzlich sich verfährt er
bisher abgründiges findet sich schon
landschaft wo im harz entspricht
ziemlich ab vom schuss nur über einen
flotten karl weg von oben herab zu
erreichen ein wüstes tristes bauernhaus
mit ungestümem da meine stimme geht an
den spoken word performer michael fehr
und damit auch an den weiten
literaturbegriff am 6 juli hat michael
fehr
den zweiten preis beim bachmann
literatur wettbewerb in klagenfurt
gewonnen
heftig dass sie diese beruhen auf der
mini krone stich verdammen und befragt
aber das wichtigste für ihn der
live-auftritt der unmittelbare kontakt
zu seinem publikum und jedes